¿Si alguien te preguntara quiénes fueron
las personas más ricas de la historia,
a quién nombrarías?
Tal vez a un banquero multimillonario
o magnate empresarial
como Bill Gates o John D. Rockefeller.
¿Qué hay del rey
africano Musa Keita I?
Al gobernar el Imperio
de Malí en el siglo XIV,
Mansa Musa, o el rey de los reyes,
amasó una fortuna
que probablemente
le convirtió en una de las personas
más ricas que han existido.
Pero su inmensa riqueza es solo
una parte de su rico legado.
Cuando Mansa Musa
llegó al poder en 1312,
gran parte de Europa estaba devastada
por el hambre y las guerras civiles.
Pero muchos reinos africanos
y el mundo islámico florecían
y Mansa Musa jugó un papel importante
en traer los frutos de este progreso
a su propio reino.
Al anexionar estratégicamente
la ciudad de Tombuctú,
y restablecer su control
sobre la ciudad de Gao,
también se hizo con las
importantes rutas comerciales
entre el Mediterráneo y la
costa de África Occidental,
continuando así su expansión, hecho que
aumentó drásticamente el tamaño de Malí.
El territorio del Imperio de Malí
era rico en recursos naturales,
como el oro y la sal.
El mundo fue testigo por primera vez
de la riqueza de Mansa Musa en 1324
cuando se fue en peregrinación a La Meca.
No fue un viaje limitado
por un presupuesto,
se llevó una caravana que era
tan larga como alcanzaba la vista.
Los recuerdos de este viaje
se basan en testimonios orales
y diferentes registros escritos,
por lo que es difícil determinar
los detalles exactos.
Pero la mayoría concuerda en
la escala extravagante del viaje.
Los cronistas describen un séquito
de decenas de miles de soldados,
civiles,
y esclavos,
500 heraldos que llevaban bastones
de oro y vestidos de sedas finas,
y muchos camellos y caballos cargando
una gran cantidad de lingotes de oro.
En sus paradas en ciudades
como El Cairo,
se dice que Mansa Musa gastó
cantidades enormes de oro,
haciendo regalos a los pobres,
comprando recuerdos,
e incluso mandando levantar
mezquitas a lo largo del camino.
De hecho, sus gastos puede que
desestabilizaran la economía regional
y causaran una inflación masiva.
Según los informes, este
viaje duró más de un año,
y para cuando Mansa Musa regresó,
las noticias de su increíble riqueza
se habían extendido hasta
los puertos del Mediterráneo.
Malí y su rey fueron elevados
al estatus de leyenda,
una vez incluidos en
el Atlas Catalán de 1375.
Uno de la más importantes
mapamundis de la Europa medieval,
representa al rey sosteniendo un
cetro y una pepita de oro reluciente.
Mansa Musa había puesto literalmente
a su imperio y a sí mismo en el mapa.
Pero las riquezas materiales no
fueron la única preocupación del rey.
Como musulmán devoto, se interesó
por Tombuctú en especial,
ya que era un centro religioso
y académico antes de su anexión.
Al regresar de su peregrinación,
hizo construir allí la
gran Mezquita Djinguereber
con la ayuda de un arquitecto andalusí.
También fundó una
importante universidad,
elevando aún más la
reputación de la ciudad
y atrajo a académicos y estudiantes
de todo el mundo islámico.
Bajo Mansa Musa,
el Imperio se urbanizó
con escuelas y mezquitas en cientos
de ciudades densamente pobladas.
El rico legado del rey
duró generaciones
y hasta la fecha, hay mausoleos,
bibliotecas y mezquitas
que son el testamento de esta
edad de oro en la historia de Malí.